The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN OPPENHEIM: Last
time, we introduced
the topic of digital
filter design,
and we discussed two
design techniques which
permitted us to obtain digital
filter designs from analog
or continuous time designs.
In particular, the first
technique that we discussed
was basically
mapping differentials
in a linear constant coefficient
differential equation
to differences in a linear
constant coefficient difference
equation.
We found that that
corresponded basically
to a mapping from the
s plane to the z plane.
But we saw also that it
was not a good technique
for two basic reasons.
One is that it didn't correspond
to mapping the frequency
characteristic from the j
omega axis to the unit circle.
And second of all, and
perhaps even more serious,
it didn't result in a mapping
of stable analog filters
to stable digital filters.
The second technique
that we discussed
was the technique of
impulse and invariance,
where basically, the
discrete time filter
is designed by
sampling periodically
the impulse response of
the continuous time filter.
And we saw that what
this corresponded to
was basically a
mapping of the system
function for the continuous
time filter to a system
function for the digital filter,
which preserved the residues
and mapped the poles of the
continuous time filter at poles
at s sub k to poles of
the digital filter at e
to the s sub k capital T.
Well, let me remind you
again of the advantages
and disadvantages
of this technique
by illustrating it
with a simple example.
Let's take the case of a simple,
second order analog filter,
let's say with one
0 and two poles,
so that the analog
system function
is given by S plus a divided
by S plus a squared plus
b squared.
For the impulse invariant
design procedure,
we want to expand this into
a partial fraction expansion.
And in that form, this system
function becomes a 1/2--
1/2 as the residu3--
divided by S plus a plus jb.
The pole is then at minus a
minus jb, plus a residue of 1/2
over S plus a minus
jb, in other words,
a pole at minus a plus jb.
All right.
Well, mapping this analog system
function to the digital system
function, we
maintain the residue
and map the pole
at minus a minus jb
to a pole in the z plane
at e to the minus a capital
T e to the minus
jb capital T. So
the resulting digital
transfer function
has these same
residues, and it has
poles which are at e to the
minus aT e to the minus jgT,
and e to the minus
aT e to the plus jbT.
And this system function,
we can now recombine.
We can recombine the two terms.
And the resulting
digital transfer function
is as I've indicated here.
Now, this illustrates one of
the important points, which
is the fact that the
poles got mapped according
to a mapping which
is of the form z
equals e to the s
capital T. But notice
that, in fact, the 0 didn't
get mapped in the same way.
The 0 at minus a got mapped,
for this particular example,
to a 0 at e to the
minus aT t cosine bT.
So in fact, it's not
a mapping of S to z,
although the poles of the
analog system function
get mapped to poles of the
digital system function
according to the mapping
z equals e to the sT.
Well, what this example looks
like in the frequency domain,
I've indicated here.
Here is the s plane
plot of the two poles
and the 0 from the
analog system function.
And the result of the
mapping or the result
of applying the impulse
invariant procedure
are the poles and 0s, which are
indicated here in the z plane.
Well, to see what happens
to the frequency response,
for this particular
analog example,
we have a resonance at a
frequency corresponding
to the vertical
position of these poles.
And that's the resonance
that we have here
in the magnitude of the
analog system function.
And one of the important
aspects of the impulse invariant
procedure, which I pointed
out last time, is that,
except for aliasing-- and
that's a big except for--
except for aliasing,
the frequency response
has the same general shape
in the discrete domain
as it does in the
continuous domain.
So the corresponding discrete
time frequency response
is as I've indicated here.
We have a resonance
corresponding
to these pole locations.
But whereas this
frequency response
drops off asymptotically to 0,
this frequency response drops
off to some value,
non-zero value,
and then continues
back up again,
basically because this frequency
response has to be periodic.
But in particular, the value
which this frequency response
decays to is dictated in part
by the effect of aliasing.
And you can see here that
in comparing this value
to this one, this is higher.
And the reason it's
higher is because
of the effect of aliasing.
So there is the advantage
to impulse invariance
that the frequency axis
is a scaled replica
of the analog frequency axis.
But then there's a
distortion that's introduced,
which is the effect of aliasing.
There's another
technique which is
a very important
and commonly used
technique for designing
digital filters, which
avoids the problem the
problem of aliasing,
but it avoids that
problem at a price.
That technique is referred to
as the bilinear transformation
and basically involves mapping
from the s plane to the z plane
by applying-- by
relating s and z
according to the bilinear
transformation, a bilinear
transformation.
There, in fact, is
an interesting way
of deriving this
technique, which
is somewhat similar
to the technique
involving mapping
differentials to differences.
But of course, the
bilinear transformation
will turn out to be a much
more useful technique.
This technique can be derived--
and we won't be going
through this in detail
here, although we
do in the text--
this can be derived
essentially by beginning
with a continuous time
differential equation,
integrating the equation to
obtain an integral equation,
and then approximating
the integrals,
using the trapezoidal rule.
In other words, replacing
the integrals by sums,
using the trapezoidal
rule for integration,
the resulting equation is
then a difference equation.
And that difference
equation will then
represent the digital filter,
and that digital filter,
as it turns out, can be related
back to the analog filter.
The system functions
can be related
through a transformation
from s to z,
which is, in fact, the
bilinear transformation.
So the technique
then is basically
to begin with an
analog system function,
convert that to a
digital system function,
and do that by replacing s
by a bilinear transformation,
where the bilinear
transformation
is as I've indicated here.
There's a parameter, capital
T, that I've introduced,
and it's a parameter
that comes in, basically,
because of what's involved
in applying the integration
or applying the trapezoidal
rule to implementing
the integration.
But this then is the general
form of the transformation.
Or expressing z instead
as a function of s,
we obtain z equals
1 plus sT over 2
divided by 1 minus sT over 2.
So one important
aspect of this then,
which, in fact, is different
than the impulse invariant
procedure, is that it,
in fact, does correspond
to a mapping from s to z.
It's a mapping of the s
plane to the z plane, which
is not quite what the
impulse invariant method is.
Well, recalling that there are
two guidelines that we set down
last time, we'd like to
verify, first of all,
whether the bilinear
transformation in fact
preserves the characteristics,
the frequency characteristics--
that is, whether it maps
from the j omega axis
to the unit circle, first.
And second of all, does it
map stable analog filters
to stable digital filters?
Well, let's look at the
first question first.
Let's look at the unit
circle and inquire as to what
part of the s plane the
unit circle came from.
So we have, then, z equals e to
the j omega on the unit circle.
And so we want to inquire
as to what values of s
land on the unit circle through
the bilinear transformation.
And we do that simply
by substituting
z equals e to the
j omega, so that s
is equal to 2 over
capital T times 1 minus e
to the minus j omega divided by
1 plus e to the minus j omega.
And now we can change
this term and likewise
the denominator term
by factoring out e
to the minus j omega over 2.
And then this
numerator term becomes
e to the plus j
omega over 2 minus
e to the minus j omega over 2.
And we recognize
this numerator then
as 2j times sine omega over 2.
Well, likewise, we can carry
out a similar manipulation
with the denominator term.
The result then is that
this can be rewritten
as 2 over capital T times j
times the tangent of omega
over 2.
Well, since omega
ranges from 0 to 2 pi,
this is always a real
number, tangent omega over 2.
And consequently, we can rewrite
this as j times a real number
capital Omega.
All right.
Well, what does that say?
It says that if z is
on the unit circle,
then s is going to be of the
form j times a real number.
And that has to have been,
then, the j omega axis.
So s equal to j omega means z
equals e to the j omega, where
capital Omega and little
omega are related by capital
Omega equal to 2
over capital T times
the tangent of
little omega over 2.
Well, that says that,
indeed, the j omega axis
gets mapped to the unit
circle, and vice versa.
And in fact, the
entire j omega axis
gets mapped to exactly once
around the unit circle.
Well, let's look at the mapping
in a little more detail.
Here we have the s plane,
and here we have the z plane.
We have the relationship between
the j omega axis and the unit
circle, that the j omega axis
gets mapped to the unit circle.
And in fact, as capital Omega
runs from minus infinity
to plus infinity, we map exactly
once around the unit circle.
Now, that's an important
point for two reasons.
One is that, obviously, there's
no aliasing involved anymore,
because the entire j
omega axis ended up once
around the unit circle.
That is, there was
nothing that got
added on to something else that
got added on to something else,
as it did with the
impulse invariant method.
The second point is that
that axis is infinitely long.
The unit circle only has
a finite circumference.
So clearly, something
has to happen.
Something has to be distorted
in order to fit all of that
onto just this little bit.
In particular,
the mapping, if we
draw it, between little
omega, angular frequency
around the unit circle, and
distance along the j omega
axis, looks as I've indicated
here, which, of course, is
a nonlinear curve.
Well, let me return
to that in a second.
An additional point about
the bilinear transformation,
which I'll state simply and
leave it to you to verify,
is that the bilinear
transformation has
the property that the
left 1/2 of the s plane
gets mapped to the interior
of the unit circle,
and the right half
of the s plane
gets mapped to the exterior
of the unit circle.
Well, that's good,
because that says
that, if we have poles or 0s--
but poles is what we really
care about right now--
we have poles in the
left 1/2 of the s plane,
they'll end up inside
the unit circle.
So if we have a
stable analog filter,
we'll end up with a
stable digital filter.
If we have an unstable
analog filter,
corresponding to poles on
the right 1/2 of the s plane,
then we'll end up with an
unstable digital filter,
corresponding to poles
outside the unit circle.
All right.
Well, now, returning to the
mapping of the j omega axis
to digital frequency, the
mapping from analog frequency
to digital frequency, one
of the important aspects
of the bilinear transformation
is that that mapping ends up
as a nonlinear mapping.
Well, what are the
consequences of that?
Let's take a look at it
in a little more detail.
And in addition to pointing
out some of the problems
that that raises, this
offers us an opportunity
to indicate how, in
fact, this distortion can
be taken into account in
implementing a digital filter
design.
So here is the frequency mapping
of the bilinear transformation.
This is digital frequency.
Here is analog frequency.
And this curve, of course,
goes out to infinity in capital
Omega and asymptotically
approaches pi, as it does that,
in little omega.
That says that the top
1/2 of the j omega axis
gets mapped to the upper
1/2 of the unit circle.
Well, suppose that we had,
say, an analog filter frequency
response that was, let's
say, linear in frequency.
Would the corresponding
digital frequency response
also be linear in frequency?
Well, the answer to that,
unfortunately, is no.
In other words, a frequency
characteristic along this axis
will get distorted
as it gets reflected
through this nonlinear curve.
For example, let's
look specifically
at a linear analog
frequency characteristic,
as I've indicated here
which might, for example, be
the frequency response
of a differentiator.
That, in fact, is the
kind of frequency response
that a differentiator
might have.
As we reflect that through
this nonlinear curve,
because of the fact
that that's nonlinear,
we don't maintain the linearity
of the analog frequency
response.
Now, if it happened that this
was the kind of frequency
response that we wanted,
we could get that
from an analog differentiator.
But more typically, what
we might be interested in
is a digital
differentiator which
would have, say, a linear
frequency characteristic.
And one of the important aspects
of the bilinear transformation
is that we couldn't design that
by designing-- by mapping over
an analog differentiator to
a digital differentiator,
using the bilinear
transformation.
Now, that's in contrast to
the impulse invariant design
procedure, where, in fact,
for an impulse invariant
design, if we have a
band-limited filter that
is linear over some part
of the frequency band,
impulse invariance
would maintain
the linearity of the
frequency characteristics.
So that's an important
distinction between these two
methods and, in fact, a drawback
to the bilinear transformation.
Well, where might we
be able to tolerate
this kind of a
nonlinear distortion
in the frequency axis?
One place we could is when
the desired digital filter
is piecewise constant,
in which case
that will get reflected into
a piecewise constant analog
filter.
And let me indicate
that more explicitly.
Let's suppose that we were
interested in designing
a digital filter, which
was a low pass filter.
Here's the magnitude axis,
and here's the frequency axis.
And the digital low
pass filter was unity,
say, in the passband, a rapid
cutoff at the passband edge,
and then 0.
Well, clearly, this
part being constant
gets reflected through this
nonlinear frequency curve
into a constant analog
frequency characteristic.
Similarly, the
stopband gets reflected
into a constant amplitude,
in this case, 0,
in the analog
frequency response.
And what's the effect of
this nonlinear distortion
in the frequency axis?
The only effect that it has
is that the cutoff frequency
of the filter or, in the more
general case, the frequencies
at which the piecewise constant
characteristic changes from one
piece to another gets changed
according to this frequency
warping characteristic.
So this cutoff frequency gets
converted into a new cutoff
frequency, where the
analog cutoff frequency is
related to the digital
cutoff frequency
according to that curve.
Now-- and so one of the
things that that says is that
for the filter design, if
we wanted to design an ideal
digital filter, an ideal
digital low pass filter,
then to decide on the
specifications for the ideal
analog filter, we
would simply pre-warp--
what's called pre-warping--
pre-warp the cutoff frequency
to an analog cutoff frequency,
which would get unraveled back
to the right cutoff frequency
when we go through the bilinear
transformation.
Now, we know that there
aren't ideal filters.
And so, in fact,
we're, in general,
faced with the problem of
approximating a characteristic
like that.
But if the specifications
for the filter
are still piecewise
constant, then, in fact,
we can still concentrate
just simply on a pre-warping
of the critical frequencies.
And the piecewise
constant portions
of the frequency
response will then
fall in the correct places.
And let me illustrate that by
showing a more realistic kind
of filter frequency response.
Well, that's pretty close.
All right.
Here we have what would be more
typical of the digital filter
that we would design
and implement--
some allowed tolerance
in the passband,
some allowed tolerance in the
stopband, a passband cutoff
frequency, and a stopband
cutoff frequency.
Well, if that was our
desired digital filter,
then how would
those specifications
translate to an analog filter?
Well, if the deviation
in the digital filter
was between 1 and 1
minus delta sub p,
then that would get
converted into specifications
on the analog filter,
likewise between 1 and 1
minus delta sub p.
The passband cutoff
edge would get
reflected through
this nonlinear curve
to a new analog
cutoff frequency.
Likewise, the transition
region would get reflected
into a new transition region.
If this frequency
characteristic was, let's say,
linear in the transition
region, of course,
it wouldn't end up linear
in this transition region.
But who cares?
The stopband edge
would get reflected
into a new stopband edge.
And finally, the
stopband specifications,
let's say, delta
sub s, would get
mapped to the same stopband
specifications, delta sub s.
Furthermore, notice
that if, let's say,
we had an optimum
filter which turns out
to be equal ripple for
the digital case, then
that would correspond to
an equal ripple filter
in the analog case.
Or said another way, if
we were able to design
an equal ripple
analog filter, then
map through the bilinear
transformation, that
would likewise result in an
equal ripple digital filter.
So the important point
here then is that we can,
for piecewise constant
frequency characteristics
and specifications, it really
is only the critical frequencies
that we care about, the edge
of the passband, the edge
of the stopband, and in the
multiple band case, of course,
there will be a number of those.
By pre-warping those through
this arctangent curve
into the corresponding
analog critical frequencies,
if this filter is then designed
and mapped to a digital filter,
using the bilinear
transformation,
then the passband
and stopband edges
will fall at the
frequencies that we want.
And this point again
will be emphasized
in the next lecture, when I
show a design example comparing
impulse invariance in the
bilinear transformation.
So the key point then about
the bilinear transformation
is that it avoids the problem
of aliasing at a price.
The price is that there's a
distortion in the frequency
axis.
And so consequently, we can only
use the bilinear transformation
to design filters that can
tolerate that distortion.
Typically, that means designing
piecewise constant digital
filters.
All right.
Well, that basically concludes
the discussion of the design
techniques that correspond to
mapping analog filter designs
to digital filter designs.
There is one final
class of techniques
that I would like to just
comment on somewhat briefly.
And that is the class of
techniques that correspond
to algorithmic design.
Now, there are algorithmic
design procedures
for analog filters.
And the same
algorithmic procedures
can likewise be used
for digital filters.
Since we have to go through
an algorithmic procedure--
in fact, there is no
advantage, in that case,
to first designing
the analog filter
and then mapping that over
to the digital filter.
Rather, for these
algorithmic techniques,
it makes more sense to
just simply apply them
directly to the design
of a digital filter.
Well, there are a number
of techniques, actually
a fairly long list, many of them
simple modifications of others.
There are only two that I want
to point to in this lecture.
When we talk about the design
of finite impulse response
filters, there are some
additional algorithmic design
procedures that we'll point to.
Well, the first algorithmic
design procedure,
which I am restricting,
in my discussion here,
to the design of infinite
impulse response filters,
the first is simply
designing the filter
to minimize the mean square
error between the desired
frequency characteristic,
the desired frequency
response, and the actual
frequency response.
So let's assume that we
have some desired frequency
response, H sub d
of e to the j omega.
We would like to match
that with the frequency
response of the rational
transfer function.
It, of course, isn't
possible to attempt
to do that at an arbitrary
number of frequencies.
So we can pick out some set
of frequencies, omega sub
i, at which we would
like to minimize
the error between
the desired frequency
response and the actual
frequency response.
The error, then,
which we'll be using,
or one error which
is used, is the error
that corresponds to minimization
of the mean square error
is the mean square difference
between the magnitude
of the actual transfer
function and the magnitude
of the desired
transfer function.
So this error, then, summed over
the frequency points at which
we specify the desired
frequency response, this error,
m is to be minimized.
Well, how do we pick H?
Well, the general form for H
is as a rational function--
that's what we've been
restricting ourselves
to throughout the discussion--
the rational function of z,
and expressed, for example,
in cascade form, involving
second order sections,
that is, two coefficients
for the 0s and two
coefficients for the poles,
with capital K sections
all together.
So basically what the
procedure then consists
of-- it's somewhat brute force--
is to specify the
order of the filter.
We then have a set
of coefficients
which we need to solve for.
We have a set of equations
which result from minimizing
this error function.
And by solving that
set of equations,
by minimizing this
error, what results then
are values for the
parameters, which
provide the parameters
for the filter
that we want to implement.
Well, one of the issues
with this method,
one of the difficulties with
it, of course, is that--
and you can kind of
imagine that this
is what's going to happen--
is that, if you take
this rational function
and put it into this equation
and minimize this error,
you end up with a
set of equations
for the a sub k's, b sub
k, c sub k, and d sub k,
but it's a set of
nonlinear equations.
And basically what the
algorithmic part of this design
procedure amounts to
is algorithmically
solving this nonlinear
set of equations.
Well, let me just illustrate,
with one simple example,
how this procedure-- what
type of filter this procedure
might lead to.
I don't want to, obviously,
go through all the details
of solving the equations.
But let's just quickly
look at an example.
This is an example incidentally
that is taken from a paper
by Professor Kenneth Steiglitz,
at Princeton University.
And the objective
here was to design
what's called a
format filter, which
is used for speech synthesis.
And the frequency
characteristic--
the aspects of the
frequency characteristic
that were important were to
have peaks at this frequency
and this frequency
and this frequency--
those are the peaks
that, incidentally,
correspond to the resonances
of the vocal tract--
and to have valleys in
between those peaks.
Well, one of the things that you
can see from the kind of filter
that we're talking
about designing here
is that this isn't
piecewise constant.
And in fact, it's
not band-limited.
And it tends to have-- it's
not arbitrary, of course,
but it's a much more general
frequency characteristic
shape than we had
been talking about
in discussing the previous
methods, in particular,
than we had been talking about
in discussing the bilinear
transformation.
Well, the procedure
that was used, then,
was to specify the values of
the desired frequency response
and to try to specify
them in such a way
that the frequency
characteristic was more
or less forced to go
through the proper values
at the important frequencies.
So what was specified,
then, was a point here.
The frequency
response was specified
to have that value
there, one here to get
us heading toward
the resonance, three
points at the peak of the
resonance there, three points
to force the frequency
response back down again,
another three to
bring it back up
for the second resonance, a few
points distributed along here
to provide a general
characteristic to tend
toward the next resonance,
three points at this resonance,
and then a few points to have
the frequency response taper
off.
Well, what was used was a total
of three second order sections.
And the resulting frequency
response that was obtained
is what is shown
here in solid lines.
And you can see
that, in fact, that's
a reasonably good fit to the
points that were specified.
This particular example I
chose to illustrate primarily,
because it is one of the
harder examples involving
the minimization of
mean square error.
And in fact, in terms of
computer time on an IBM 36065,
this particular example
required approximately 2 and 1/2
minutes.
So that's a reasonable
amount of computation,
but one of the
important aspects to it
is that it allows the design,
and it allowed the design,
of a somewhat general
frequency shape,
frequency characteristic.
All right.
So that is one
algorithmic method.
And it, in fact,
is a good method.
It's one of the methods
that is commonly used,
particularly when
the frequency--
when some of the other methods--
the bilinear transformation
or impulse invariance
can't be used, because the
filter isn't of a simple form.
But one of the major
disadvantages to it
is the fact that the
equations that result
are not linear equations.
And in general, solving
nonlinear equations
is a fairly difficult
algorithmic job.
Well, there's an
alternative to that,
which is a method which is
commonly referred to as least
squares inverse design.
And in that design
procedure, we can
imagine specifying a
desired impulse response.
And in this case, we restrict
the filter transfer function
to have no 0s and only poles.
Well, it turns out-- and
I don't want to elaborate
on the details--
but basically, the way
this procedure is set up
is to consider a system
whose system function is
the inverse of H of z, so that
that system is in all 0 system,
and then choose as an
input to that system
the desired unit
sample response.
Now, we have the desired unit
sample response is the input.
We've got the
reciprocal of the filter
that we're going to implement
in this as the system function.
And if, in fact, the
realized unit sample response
was exactly equal to the desired
unit sample response, what
would the output be?
Well, it would be a unit
sample, because this
would be exactly the inverse
of this unit sample response.
Well, let's think of
the output as g of n.
And ideally, g of n should
be an impulse, a unit sample.
Well, in general, of course,
it won't be, since H sub d of n
we won't be able to fit exactly
by a model of that form.
So let's consider
the error, which
is the mean square
difference between g
of n and a unit sample.
And that then is the
error that we minimize.
So the idea behind the
least squares inverse design
is basically to design the
inverse to the desired unit
sample response, do
that by minimizing
the mean square error
between the output
of this inverse system
and the desired output.
And the desired output, of
course, is a unit sample.
Well, there's the
legitimate question
as to whether that is a
reasonable error criterion
to use.
It's, of course, a possible
error criterion to use.
But one could ask,
why in the world
would you want to set
up the problem that way?
Well, there's a
very good reason.
The reason is that,
if you do that,
minimize this error in
terms of these coefficients,
the equations that result
are linear equations.
And linear equations are
simple equations to solve,
as opposed to
nonlinear equations.
So this is a technique
that, in fact, turns out
to be a good technique for
a wide variety of filters.
It has the important
advantage that it
leads to a set of
linear equations,
as opposed to the minimization
of mean square error,
which leads to a set
of nonlinear equations.
Well, this is just
a very quick glimpse
at two algorithmic
design procedures.
As I said previously,
there are some others,
which we won't be going
into, some of which
are described in the text.
And there are a few related to
finite impulse response filters
that we'll be discussing
in a number of lectures.
In the next lecture,
what I would like to do
is review the impulse invariant
and bilinear design procedures,
since those are the
two major design
procedures for infinite
impulse response filters,
review those two procedures
through a design example.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]